ma diciamo che era un po che non
registrava con i miei amici cose a caso
per poi metterle sul canale siamo su
play erano ragazzi che non gioco tipo
antico gli hunger games dove siamo in
100 persone dobbiamo sopravvivere noi
per ultimi rispetto a tutti gli altri ci
sono anche le armi quindi un casino
vi lascio al video della ragazza allora
stiamo facendo questo video perché
l'ultima volta abbiamo scritto sto
parlando io stiamo facendo noi più
scritto perché lui perché l'ultima volta
preghiera non e ai posso dire la fase
che volevo dire che mancano 38 secondo
dinamici e l'ultima volta che abbiamo
giocato a preghiera non abbiamo fatto
schifo perché non sapevamo giocare
adesso ci siamo imparati nell'ultimo
periodo
ti facciamo più che gare di prima prova
bene grazie alla mi ha fatto dire
comunque il 90 per cento di quello che
volevo dire soprattutto soddisfatto da
partendo mai mai mai
l'i pod california 321 via vai di
boccali panca piace un team che per nord
ma noi siamo più forti e noi ci sono 26
team se porterà a me l'idea molto
intelligente che ha detto di andare a
questa città del caso bravo vaio c muoio
io poi non voglio combattere di una moto
o chiari che c'è un in questa casa
tranquillo forse non prendo prima gli
orari e lo prende da dietro bene a me
piace che cotanto un po incontrato un po
va chiuso se non fai in tempo a sera al
cav h non fa in tempo a salire cassel e
stura ios aprendo alcuni bonus sono a
terra
una morte un ne mando a terra come sede
di google è un ufo di al cortisone ed ai
chieti da ucciso ma chi se ne frega
vieni ho capito ma se arriva mentre ti
sto rianimando sono una merda io che ho
ucciso una persona amici bravo gianni e
ho fatto più far fuori più personale
l'ultimo episodio siamo
all'inizio quindi la lista che ha
sposato con la scusa per questa
quest'anno può di sicuro ci saluta
aspetta i cento passi e pagani primario
50 quella di laura di la continua ha
bisogno di giuliana giusy porcata e non
è da juve qua ho capito ma non entrò
limitavo addosso ma ovviamente si entra
romperle partito che qualcuno di armi
per il prodotto di una grazia arrivare
aspetta non capisco questo non riguarda
solo non farlo solo se andiamo occhio
che potrebbe buttare e mi sono pagato
anch'io l'ho detto e lo so pensa se non
lo dicevi spegniamo il computer
le case porca vacca quando ragazzi ce la
facciamo gli strali di la mia parte la
mia parte la mia parte l'ho ammazzato il
quadretto caso da me capito ma esci
aiuto degli accessi e non ci sono
entrato nella porta dock i suoi porti
faccio sono uscito dall'apartheid che
poi abbiamo fatto fuori quello che dovrà
far fuori prima
ok ma gli altri e gli altri non lo so
abbiamo fatto fuori quattro persone che
dovrebbero esserci nessuno spiega
macchina bravo luca 3 euro è tanto che
il cast serve che con
ma dài dài giù in un grande partito
aspetto aspetto abbiamo timore che si ma
il filmato lo stronzo a pieve lasciate
giu le persone vita a prendermi ho
capito scusa nonna casa a [ __ ] d'uva
donna tanto non ci siamo fatti neanche
troppo male madonna luca mikako addosso
ad asti militare valutiamo veloce lo fa
sparano qua allora allora non volare da
fare non è stata colpa mia non è stata
colpa mia ma che cazzo è successo e cosa
cazzo è successo sabato per lo più corre
a piedi per questa macchina stavo con
affanculo pietra vado io sulla moto io
stanno intervita monete devi morire mi
sarei barone sono troppo ma come dove
dove [ __ ] dove la gente sai cosa il
consenso salvo amici lui ma lo sparo una
strana sparano stava bene e vabbè ma che
figlio della merda ma fatti i cazzi tuoi
il gas forse riesca velino è bellissimo
ma come la farina noi sono morto tanto
voglio sempre per pario cava caschi
collar a gaeta ho capito visto anche
chiedeva sparato proprio è ma come
faccio sotto il po lontano da dove
prende una macchina
ahi ahi ahi ahi a 10 kg ero malato va da
poveri ma d'attoma e vabbè ma l'ho visto
no mi sembra di non so mi chiama giù e
mi ha ucciso il messia non lo so non
capisco non ho visto nessuno poi ti vai
luca siamo tutti contenti
bravo l'idea grandissimo amore amore
all'idea
basta importunare i miei amici
aspetta fatti spara in faccia no perché
alla prima avevamo un team contro
l'estonia non solo due persone
ok posso scommettere perché mi perdiamo
mai non sono andati suonati nel portone
pone trova 34 nardi e la macchina ok io
mi vedo già in tal modo sono solo al
molo contenere che ho trovato un 16 cioè
il casinò di gente che cazzo due persone
che si amano ma c'è una misura nate
subito laribi milano di impersonare
sporca [ __ ] che claudio se tu sei tra
gap e sentire pensate che [ __ ]
sentivo i passi dicevo dove cazzo è che
lo sento ovunque avete dei 5 56 no
partito un fiore state gamma nero giallo
verde
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi o no no no no no
questo la donna che mi sono salvato male
arca h maniera arrivati olio non di
gloria ci sono anche i nemici vuol dire
occhio dove dove ea eccola raggio laggiù
650 centro nord esserti uno è morto è 30
30 occhio litania occhio lì dietro
dietro questi con te la danno e luca
l'attesa faccio vedere gli altri scafo
in mezzo giro ma tu l'hai ucciso questo
occhio aspetta se non a luca nello sport
occhio alla cir invece luciano dietro
sta entrando dove porca [ __ ]
la telefonata dvd ma porca vacca
schifosa siamo solo io e te che va alle
donne che lo faccia che vedete di
possiamo dire qua
ahi ahi ahi che stavate lo vedo madonna
vi faccio un culo e invece ti spa invece
mi ammazza locali sei lì sei esposto va
bene siamo difensori della patria tant'è
che mi sta sparando perché non vedrò
eccolo eccolo visto ma [ __ ] va ok
subito è morto c'era un per otto ohm
perotto pacchi la macchina ma calore gas
gas
ahi ahi ahi
per un taxi porti in piazza del duomo
sono 25 euro più mangia cadetti della
mattina ma che spendi così ad andare in
piazza del duomo perché il mio tassista
sembra tipo uscito da chernobyl by tra
l'altro docente dove c'è gente manteneva
di 20 alle 16 dice di queste scemo ma
perché scema questo è drogato ma guida
quando gente sul ponte non possiamo sì
che passiamo ma dai
guido io quale deficiente ajo perotto
scusa ma metterlo sul gas che fai lì
fuori
arca vacca e prego fai cecchinare
tieniti la solenne 6 dice ok inter e
hacker che lotta che lungo la bora che
ci beccano da dietro come minimo ma lo
so io no ma io sono buttati giù
no non avalli lo vedo vedove dei piedini
quale pd ne è un po è quello si sposta
per ora che stiamo rischiando troppo è
tanto la macchia vanti porto
poi colpito eh vabbé non muore mai però
lasciato il beatles ma tema non muore ma
mi chiama l'ho preso fortissimo in
faccia il resto è bravo rush lasciate
coprono ok non è giù né giu nessuna
pista è la madonna a iaia
no no con lei dai dai dai ma poi se uno
va giù perché devi andare sull'altro
niente adesso muoio rifaccio continua a
caricare si è beccato faccio una cosa
avvenuta probabilmente morirà me ne
sbatto infatti già di stampa lato ma non
puoi prendiamo si prepara a una buccia
bombola d occhio
ah ok perfetto e non poteva dire questo
prima no per esagera erano di pietro ha
deciso di essere un lottatore colpi ma
non l'ho beccato ma [ __ ] a non
soci chimere né un cine longo il disco
però porca vacca se morisse
ormai non ho più colpite carpiva doveva
morire farlo diventa guerra che fanno
abbastanza da napolitano non sono tutti
quanti progressi
esatto ma dai veramente l'ho ucciso io
non è vero ma tornano disintegrato devo
ammettere che è stato un bel duello gesù
prendimi jolo poi morto non solo quindi
ragazzi questa era la partita su
play.com se non migliore botto rispetto
all'ultima volta anche se facciamo
ancora decisamente cagare però va bene
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi non
lasciate che guidio le macchine se ci
fosse mai langer games siete nella merda
e i ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
cose che vi rinunciò condividere che
cazzo detto anche vari social che come
individuato nella descrizione ci sono
riusciti siener ci mettiamo in seguito
da ragazzi val cavargna sull'albero
europee
[Musica]